I'm ready
what do you think huh
um no no this is not a gym this is like
a scene out of saw five you haven't even
looked around yet look
gravel bucket squat yoke
right
dedicated phone book ripping station
you ever cut 10 before no five yards in
and your forearms will be on fire plus I
will buy the 10 back from you that you
cut for two cents a yard
now let's go over membership I'm going
to need the first months and the last
months up front for 49 a month but every
third month is 59 a month but the fourth
month is Discount month at 19 per month
obviously you know how a gym works so
you know I'm not gonna pay money for
this you want people to come to your gym
make a real gym
Daryl
Dunder Mifflin Dwight Schrute
please hold
shrut Farms guten tag how can I help you
yes we have availability on those nights
how many in your party
oh no I'm sorry no King beds
no Queen either well we make our own
mattresses that don't conform to the
traditional sizes
closest would be twin
thank you so much for calling call back
again I'll feed a zane
you know what none of your business Jim
bed and breakfast is not a BNB
agritourism is a lot more than a bed and
breakfast it consists of tourists coming
to a farm showing them around giving
them a bed giving them breakfast
does the Department of Health know about
this I am not telling you anything
permits are pending
Dwight trooped under Mifflin hello I'm
looking for a room okay this is a misuse
of company phones it says here you cater
to the elderly where did you read that
TripAdvisor
TripAdvisor is the lifeblood of the
agritourism industry a couple of bad
reviews there you may as well close up
shop that's what took down the stock in
one of the cutest little asparagus farms
you'll ever see
how many in your party
two
we offer our tours of the fields and of
the barn uh perhaps you'd be interested
in Moses table making demonstration
do white why is the toilet paper only
half apply oh I'm sorry is that not good
enough for your anus
don't get me started on how coddled the
modern anus is okay
um Stanley maybe you can just unspool a
little more each time you need to don't
tell me how to do my business
Stanley
as a fellow Dunder Mifflin employee I
feel for you but like you I am
completely powerless to the whims of the
new building owner which is you which is
you is not a sentence I disagree with
are you going to just sit there office
administrator are you going to do
something
Dwight
when I'm sitting at this I'm a Salesman
if you want to talk to the new building
owner you should call Nate and schedule
an appointment I'm not going to do that
well then you're not going to talk to
the new building owner
which is a shame because I hear he's a
very reasonable guy
oh wait
oh hey put you on hold just for one anti
SEC sure
do I true
tell her I'm busy
I don't know make something up
hey Pam Dwight's being questioned by the
police in connection with a string of
dog nappings that happened
Dwight
Dwight can you please tell the new
building owner that he is screwing over
all the people he works with people he's
worked with for years his friends
you're right
this isn't just a business
this is a home
and I would much rather see a smile from
Kevin than save hundreds on plumbing and
electricity
hello welcome to hey place a place for
hay don't forget to make a broom oh the
petting zoo closes at two and the Goat
roast is at three
come on in enjoy hey
I'm kind of in the mood for a role in
the hay rolling the hay five dollars no
I meant
oh a contract
so why don't we meet at the usual spot
uh I've got half an hour during lunch in
between the historical reenactment of
the Dunmore Farm Slaughters and the
onion boil perfect so excuse me get off
of there those are show Bales not play
bales
kids was that fun yeah all right I want
to go on it again oh I bet you do you
know what when I was a little kid they
couldn't get me off the hayride but it's
gonna cost you three more bucks
wow this brings back memories
hey stacking hey throwing
and at the end of it all one lucky boy
would be crowned hey King
I always wanted to be hey King
but the world Shines on most
and now by a show of Applause we will
Crown this year's hey King all in favor
of purebred
put your hands together for mixed bread
and let's hear it for purebred
we're appear to have a three-way tie
I have no choice but to pick the hey
King myself
I pick
me
I am your hey King oh hail your hay King
did I truck 300 bales of hay to a
parking lot to rectify some childhood
disappointment
yes
wow late every day this week we signed
CC up for this daycare and it's on the
other side of town the traffic is why
didn't I think of this before did you
know that there is a daycare center
opening right here in this building
is there really now that I own the
building I'm looking for new sources of
revenue and a daycare center
[Laughter]
well I guess it's not an evil idea it's
just a regular idea but
there's no good laugh for a regular idea
welcome to the Sesame Avenue daycare
center for infants and toddlers
ah you remember my cousin Moz welcome
children were you painting in the dark
wait is this your place Dwight oh no no
I like to think of it as the kids place
would you like a tour
I don't think we're really oh let's take
the tour Pam yeah come on
here is the language skills and
cognitive development area
these are English uh letters I see you
found our magical toy box Jim these are
actually forks and knives from the break
room Jim to you and me maybe but come on
to a child's imagination that's Mr fork
and Lieutenant knife and Miss fork and a
soy sauce packet
become fully equipped with a restroom
feeding trough play bucket and room for
a plant in success who will be watching
the children no one the door locks from
the outside Escape is impossible prove
it
what we're gonna head outside
let's give it a whirl I just want to see
how it works oh no no I don't tell you
this if this works out I think
we're looking I promise you that door
locks
Jim Jim
Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim Jim
Jim
[Music]
oh hey do what
I'm going to be your new boss
it's my greatest dream come true welcome
to the Hotel Hell check-in time is now
checkout time is never does my room have
cable no and the sheets are made of Fire
can I change your rooms sorry we're all
booked up hell convention in town can I
always check out I'll have to talk to
the manager you're not the manager even
in your own fantasy
I'm the owner
the co-owner with Satan
okay
just so I understand that in your
wildest fantasy you are in hell
and you are co-running a bed and
breakfast with the Devil yeah but I
haven't told you my salary yet go
eighty thousand dollars a year once I'm
officially regional manager my first
order of business will be to demote Jim
Halpert
so I will need a new number two
my ideal choice
Jack Bauer
but he is unavailable
fictional and overqualified